it what's up guys mkbhd here and you're
watching a special edition of ask mr.
wonderful where you guys ask the
questions and we answer I mean we were
just sitting back you know
chopping it up reminiscing about the
good ol days another track of my roots
where I came from you want to talk Tech
I got the tech guy here marques is the
man today well answer your questions
about anything ready let's go
hey mr. wonderful and mkbhd you both
have strong personal brands how
different was your journeys since you
built your brands at different times and
also what advice would you give to
someone who wants to build their
personal brand in the next few years to
come so definitely write about different
times and different methods I can say
that my personal brand was built by just
being really genuine about my passion
for tech and putting it in video form
controlling all of that evolving the
craft and posting it online and so I
kind of think that's if I gave any
advice for someone today where that
particular method is easier than ever I
would say to stay true something you're
passionate about you know do you have
the goal of just making money that's not
good enough
and then to just be comfortable with
doing it until it eventually succeeds I
take a stab at it this way if your
mandate in your life is to just build
your personal brand you will fail that's
not how it works you have to be
transparent and honest about something
you know a lot about or at least feel
very passionate about and people feel
that connection and if they connect
because they believe you and you're
honest it'll work and I'll tell you
something you should understand people
smell [ __ ] a mile away it's true
real fast and if you just can't do it
without bullshitting them you are never
gonna get anywhere so try and be honest
and see if you can actually play it out
that way not everybody can do it this
guy built a huge brand my son is a
massive
fan of his because he'd said dad that
guy just tells the truth wherever it
goes that's it that's why he's a rock
star so if I were to summarize what the
mkbhd brand is it's kind of in the name
mkb is my initials and HD stands for
high definition but what that really
sort of means is it's a high quality
look at technology and it's an honest
look like you mentioned I tell the truth
and that's kind of the whole point so if
you're trying to figure out if
something's worth buying I'm gonna use
it and tell you if it is worth buying or
if it's not and you're gonna get the
cold hard truth and in a quality
entertaining informative way let me ask
you a question sure remember Walter
Musburger Walt Mossberg yeah yeah one of
the things he did right he he was your
predecessor in some ways you know brand
could ever convince him to become a
spokesperson for them if he didn't use
it but he didn't like it he didn't
believe in it right you're kind of the
same way I bet all kinds of companies
particularly consumer electronics want
you to give the endorsement to them yeah
and you have to fight that back with a
stick yeah how do you get away with that
well I mean it sort of was built up that
way I was doing this before it was ever
a business so companies would come along
and offer money like he said to be a
spokesperson and the obvious answer was
no because I didn't use it and I didn't
really feel passionately about it and it
didn't matter now that it is a business
you would think it would be like more
tempting to deviate from that path but
it's it's sort of so ingrained now that
I continued to make the choice of only
working with companies and products that
I actually care about that it just feels
natural
so that's justify are you okay being
critical too oh absolutely that's
actually usually more helpful than
praise you know you see praise for good
products all the time I love this thing
it's so great it's so fast and make my
life easy but the criticism of the bad
things is what helps them make their
next version or their software update
better so I find oftentimes the
criticism is actually more valuable than
the praise I was sitting with a bunch of
engineers at work on the battery
opposite Tesla last week and I said I
was going to be doing this with you they
went out of their minds
they said look that guy is the straight
dope he just calls it the way it is and
we love that yes that is your brand yeah
the no [ __ ] aspect absolutely fairly
recently you've had a you know bigger
companies sort of invite me behind the
curtain behind the scenes to talk with
engineers and executives and even hi you
know public facing people out there
companies and to an extent there's a lot
of trust involved in that like you said
there's there's a risk in me you know I
think does it change there when you're
sitting there realizing you're on the
other side of the curtain now does that
change the way you ask a question does
it to make you does it you force
yourself to edit yourself no so I I kind
of put myself in the shoes of who's
going to end up watching this which is
what what I want to know what I wanted
is and that's what I want to ask I want
to feel like I can I can deliver
something because of my access that
order not of ordinarily did they lay
down any ground rules on you it would
depend on who the interviews with I've
actually found tech to be some of the
least restrictive I just because I spoke
with you know like a real a Lister Will
Smith for example and they're working
with like Disney and Paramount and
they're they're you know trying to focus
the questions on a certain thing but a
lot of these tech guys just sort of like
talking tech so it's never really been a
problem so you don't have the PR people
squeezing your head to keep promoting
something not yet that's a beautiful
thing
[Music]
the mr. wonderful brands simply by
telling the truth and I take a lot of
heat for telling the truth -
particularly entrepreneurs who don't
want to hear their ideas no merit it is
bankrupt but the truth is the markets
gonna bite their hiney anyways so if you
get you can't get past me the markets
gonna eat you alive anyway so and I
really feel that telling the truth helps
people doesn't mean they love you but it
in the long run it helps them and so I'm
not the mean shark I'm the shark that
tells the truth get off my back stop
bugging me I got to get you in to watch
man like that's you know well I'm gonna
ask you about my watch that's a piece of
consumer electronics it absolutely is
and you know again because I'm mr.
wonderful I want to tell you the truth
when you walk in a room with that on
your wrist you're telling everybody I'm
20% off retail
you want to get a watch that talks about
you as you know it's a style thing know
what I'm saying Fred I wouldn't be
caught dead with that on my wrist so
here's how I see it okay cuz I I kind of
see parallels in the car industry and
anyway you know an investment watch yes
versus a utility watch yes so when I
when I'm walking down the street and I
get a notification on my phone and this
shows up and I can just dismiss it real
quick right well someone calls me and I
don't have to take my phone in my pocket
I'm just hanging on to the subway with
one hand and I can take the call real
quick and then end it that is some of
the things that I value in a utility
watch where if I was just buying a
fashion piece or an investment watch or
I have different goals whether I wanted
to appreciate in value or I want to look
better this is not what I would choose
so what would be cool for you would be
to have a blotch that speaks to you from
a style perspective or an investment
perspective and
the electronics utility right you know
the other day I looked I was looking at
this watch and a woman beside me who I
didn't know said what time is it I said
I have no idea she said you just looked
at your watch I said that is nothing -
at the time I'm appreciating the art the
mastery of making this piece which is
one of ten in the world and it just
brings a tear to my eye and I love to
look at it yeah I have no idea what time
it is I don't care yeah yeah that what a
what a watch is about holy and you see
the same thing in cars too right sure
someone will just love and appreciate a
car sitting in their garage beautifully
I might not drive this thing but once a
year but I can look at and admire it for
the mechanical art that it is or I can
buy a borderline piece of tech an
electric car at Tesla yeah and it's just
getting me from point A to point B over
and over and over and I'm saving money
because I don't buy gas and gives all
these other values to it well maybe it's
because you're a young guy but at some
point you want to appreciate the art the
mastery of a man spending a thousand
hours to make something that has no
reason to exist other than it's a piece
of art because that watch yeah it tells
the time a lot better than this piece of
art right but this thing costs four
thousand times what that does and I
appreciate what this person did with his
life to make this thing what is this
watch and should I get it or is that not
the appropriate well this is an F P
Jordan centa graph of which there are
only ten on earth it sounds like I can't
afford that
this is number six I'll tell you what it
costs it's about eighty thousand dollars
but but it's not it's not about the
money it's about that the F P Jordan who
was actually Picasso alive if you could
buy a Picasso from Picasso in the South
of France walk into a studio and say I
really love that I'm gonna buy it from
you and I know who you are that would be
really what's happening here with an F P
Joran right so when a man only makes ten
watches he's really gutting his soul for
you because it's not doing it for the
money
that's like the
the McLaren GTR like special edition
exists in the world exam this they can
only make so many before that does that
sing to you would you like to own one of
those cars you're a car guy I'd say I'm
more of a car guy than a watch guy and I
can make those parallels and I
appreciate the the mastery of the
mechanical design of a watch in the same
way but let's say I want to get a watch
and I can't go headfirst into the
McLaren GT of watches where should I
start the watch that I think would be
perfect for you as a starter watch would
probably be the Patek Phillipe 5711 and
Nautilus it is the most pursued watch on
earth today is steel with a blue face
yeah but it is a beautiful mastery of
what Patek Phillipe is all about that's
my face it's like copying some of that
yeah I know but like that ain't a Patek
I know but the point is when you walk in
a room with that people that love
watches know right away that you respect
the mastery of making something like
that and also that you would have one
says Patek really digs you okay yes
there's a thousand guys around the world
that want one of those but it's
difficult to actually get I think I
could help you out okay did you have to
make that decision that I want to get
there all right that might be something
I can I can dip my feet into just you
know I ever the thing is watch
collecting once you get that bug is a
horrible disease I wouldn't wish it on
anybody you get your purse protecting
say wow I really loved in the waist this
is working with me in my style statement
and I want more then your
my case you stepped it up you call cars
utilities and yet you stepped up as one
of the first guys to buy the cyber truck
which I thought was a crazy chicken
design when I saw it not alone yeah but
I know I went too why did why didn't you
decide to buy curious why you say you
want one too because this is something
that grew on you with a lot of other
people but when you first saw it when I
first saw it okay I first saw and I'm
sure you would give a damn what you
thought I said I don't need that like I
went into the event knowing we're gonna
see a pickup truck and I walked in
saying we're gonna see a pickup truck
and I'm not gonna get it because I don't
need a pickup truck right it rolls out
on stage it since it's wild the I must
here in the room changes everyone has
the same pulled back reaction like what
are we really looking at right now is
this real that the presentation goes on
or eventually convinced that it's real
he goes through its merits and typically
Elon style and even after all that I was
not convinced I wanted one but then in
in Tesla fashion the test drive was
actually the first and you're one of the
guys that got to test drive I was the
first one to get a test ride I mean that
says it all
and so that was the beginning of my my
switching over and this has happened to
me in tehsils before but you know it's
it's roomy inside you're not thinking
about the design anymore you're thinking
about how fast this thing is how quiet
the thing is and what finally rolled me
over into purchasing or reserving yeah
as you'd say is we're actually shooting
a bunch of car videos for for our tech
channel now and we would have at at some
point in the next year or two anyway
needed to get another utility vehicle to
shoot the car video for just a street of
cars to put all the stuff in the mean
and rest second vehicle to do that you
have those rolling shots and all the
sorts of things
we thought about a minivan because you
can hang out the side or you maybe a
pickup truck which we have used because
you can hang out the back of the bed it
turned out this cyber truck is sort of
the best version of all of these things
how are you gonna actually open the back
of the cyber truck to be able to shoot
clean out of the back the same way we
did when we did it out of a
f-150 or whatever it was in West Palm
Beach you can take the back off you can
either take the back off or put it
halfway down and tie it to the sides so
that you can use it as sort of a bed for
holding the stabilizer it's also silent
so you can mic up whatever beautiful now
to take any flat because it's almost
like a Humvee you know it's like a
really big honking military sized
monster yes the design is definitely
still that that hard to get over hump
for me and for many others but you know
they're starting to drive it around a
little bit in LA they're good they're
getting eyes on it it's gonna be in tons
of press in the next three years by the
time it comes out I think it's gonna
grow on people and it's going well me I
want that black stealth carbon look Sam
that's the one yeah and I want that to
drive up and down to our cottage with
the larger battery full of full of crap
and I don't want to have to charge it at
the top and I want to be able to come
back down right looks like 350 miles
maybe right yeah so the the triple motor
and the the biggest battery of 500 miles
yeah well that's what I'm gonna be
getting yeah I mean look it's not a
pickup chopper truck it's some kind of
other thing but it's grown on me and you
know that Elan guy kind of steps ahead
he kind of reminds me of Steve Jobs in a
way I used to work for Steve and
educational software and I'd always say
to him Steve what about the research he
said screw the research people don't
know what they want till I tell them and
I said you arrogant prick how can you
say that and he was 100% right yeah that
was it yeah he was he was not an easy
guy to work for I gotta tell you yeah
every time I get to ask someone by
working with Steve it's a fascinating
story so and I'm trying to be nice yeah
hey mr. wonderful my name is Kendall I
just wanted to ask you what is your
approach to breaking down doors of
opportunity I'm in the music business
and I sing I write I do the whole thing
but obviously struggling to break
through so I'm down for the fight I'm
going to do whatever it takes to make me
and my business successful so I just
wanted to know what do you think it's
too far to go for yourself and breaking
down this barrier
and what do you think isn't enough all
right Kendall great question when I
think of my own last 10 years you know
specifically in tech and in in media the
best procedure for me has always been to
make the best possible thing and then
let the craft speak for itself and the
word organic comes to mind specifically
as a as a way of of letting things build
and grow so I was always sort of against
like paying for ads on videos and things
like you know you know doing extra work
to like sort of promote this video I
would almost be happier if not enough
people watched it but the people that
watched it really liked it rather than
the opposite which was a ton of people
watch it but uh you know the video
wasn't good enough and and it wasn't
really as effective so I always biased
towards putting pouring all the effort
into the craft itself production value
the production the value of the content
all of that and and then letting the
rest sort of organically grow from that
okay I'll take a crack at a little
differently you want to advance your
feeling you're getting held back when
you meet with people that can help you
grow your career or get your objective
done or helped you with your mandate
think about it this way because this is
advice I give to everybody that's trying
to get a job or move up or even advance
their own business if you had 15 minutes
with somebody you wanted to work with
and you talk about yourself for those 15
minutes that's a mistake what you should
be talking about is how you can solve
problems for them all the hires in my
companies and the people I hire within
my own you know venture capital firm and
private equity firm our people that came
to me with really short resumes
basically one line saying I need to meet
you because I'm gonna solve some big
problems for you and help you build your
business a lot faster
that's it I'm interested I want to hear
what you have to say I don't care where
you went to high school what the name of
your dog was I couldn't care less but if
you've done some work and you could tell
me how you can advance what I'm trying
to do
you're hired Kendall and then I'll give
you six months to go prove it do that
all the time and
it really works think about that think
about talking to people about how you
can affect their outcome and you will be
a very very popular woman hey Kevin I've
heard some of the pessimist about the
stock market recently point to the
activity going on in the repo market as
a sign of an impending economic disaster
I was wondering if you could explain why
the banks are doing this and if it's any
cause for concern Thanks so mark you
know the repo market is about liquidity
and it's a technical term for a lot of
people that don't understand it but here
in New York it's very important the
reason people have been a little nervous
about it of late is there's less and
fewer banks now as a result of what's
happened in the market so repo doesn't
matter it's about liquidity of cash
basically but what really drives the
market long term is economic activity
we're gonna have 2% GDP growth next year
most likely maybe 2.1 the domestic
economy is on fire technology is the
most advanced of all those sectors has
been phenomenally successful why because
it adds productivity to the other 10
sectors we have 11 sectors in the
economy tech is one of them but
technology drives productivity in every
sector and so what has made America work
so well is the fact that we advanced so
many great technologies a question marks
emerging though because China is
graduating 250,000 engineers a year and
they're not making shitty little pencils
anymore these guys are really advancing
in some areas that we're falling behind
in 5g AI facial-recognition all kinds of
things that they're challenging us on so
it's a new global economy and I'd argue
to you maybe you want to invest globally
I do
I don't just own the Fang stocks I own
56 international internet giants because
I don't know who's gonna win what do you
think yeah I can't speak to any of the
technicalities of it but what I will say
is you know in the sort of when I think
about it in tech the decision about
whether to buy something now or to wait
because something better seems to be on
the horizon
that's kind of always going to be the
case especially in tech so you know new
phone comes out three or four new phones
are all sitting there in front of you
and you're thinking well one of these
seems to be the best but should I wait
for the next generation or this in
coming on the horizon better opportunity
that will always be the case and so if
you just buy the best of what's
available to you now and make the best
of it until that next opportunity then
that's just as good as you can do so
that's my my tech version of that that's
been that way you will always own
something yeah so one of the most
popular questions I hear especially in
smart phones is are these companies
holding back features or advancements in
their products in order to intentionally
make the next version better so they can
they can hold back that one little thing
they know in their back pocket for next
year and then sell that next year and
then the next one they hold back
something else is that intentional is
that real and I don't think that that's
real and it's really easy to think it is
but here's why you want to win now and
that will build up your potential for
winning more in the future so why would
you hold back your current product in
any way if you essentially will have all
your competitors do that thing that
you're not doing and then you can move
forward in the future and that's already
your disadvantage there's very unique
cases of companies like Apple or Google
where they're in such a position where
they can make some stranger decisions
and not necessarily have to fall in line
with the competition but the competition
is chomping at the bit so hard and doing
everything they possibly can every year
so there's no reason if you're part of
that competition not to do that so at
the end of the day I don't think most
companies are holding back features in
the tech world in their back pocket
because tech moves fast well let me ask
you a specific question about exactly
that it seemed to me last year and even
for the last 18 months that the Apple
camera was substandard or not as good as
what was on a Samsung
and as a result I bought both because
when I was taking photographs
particularly with the wide-angle
um last year Samsung ten it was a
spectacular image that I couldn't get on
the Apple phone they didn't seem to care
they stepped up with the third lens now
and I would say they're comparable but
that was a lag of a whole generation of
phones so Apple in particular has to do
or very frequently will do something
that you might call a second mover
advantage where they they'll sit back
for one year and let these newer
features an under display fingerprint
reader these new ultra wide cameras and
these these subtle new technologies sort
of bubble up and see which ones hook and
there's such a massive company with such
a massive they're almost like the the
odd one out and their strategy that they
can wait that one year and then when it
turns out look every single other phone
out there is doing ultra wide-angle
camera and they all love it then they
can come in the next year and do it well
so that's what happened he so that's
typically what happens with Apple and
and with the bigger features where
they're sort of driving our own
direction like the headphone jack moving
that out doing wireless audio they can
be pioneers with things like that but
really pushed me off like gosh they're
not alone at all on that but yeah when
you see when you look at Apple you sort
of have to take that that second thought
about where they are in the market
because they can wait a little bit on
those smaller features but generally
they want to give people the best
product they can to sell as many as
possible so hey thanks for watching
everybody and we'll catch you in the
next one
AC I mean we would just say in fact you
know chopping it up reminiscing about
the good old days or not it tracking my
roots where I came from
[Music]
but like I say always city it's not
about the destination listen this was a
fantastic ask mr. Wonderful's they keep
getting better that's why I love doing
this this question is Connie the
dangling carrot it hang from the river
your dreams in the past ain't no where
did you backseat drivers got nothing but
Seuss's shotgun riders to buy and say
y'all iose I should get a hey forever
and I'm too tired but I'm never giving
up this one kind of
[Music]